hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast achieving reproducibility
don't rent antibodies be available in
your experiment and robert test elements
of lab woods and i'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
cell signaling technology just annoying
technology CST is a private family owned
company guns by scientists and dedicated
to providing the world's highest quality
innovative research and diagnostic
products to accelerating biological
understanding and in evil personalized
medicine our employees operate worldwide
from our US headquarters and
Massachusetts and our offices in the
Netherlands China and Japan for more
information please visit South signal
calm we have a few important
announcements before we begin the
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by tackling them in the Q&A
box which can be found by clicking on
the green to an a button at the lower
left of the presentation wyndham will
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge a slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide wyndham
if you have any technical problems
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left this is an educational
webinar unless offers free continuing
education credit after blog and hours
over please click on the CD button
located the bottom left hand corner of
your web page and follow the process of
obtaining credits I would like to
introduce today's speaker dr. Anthony
Covina dr. to BN has worked at selfie
million technology for almost seven
years in various capacities as a product
development scientist he conceived
validated and released over a hundred
antibody products
recently dr. Kalina was in charge of the
csts unique coast transitional
modification and motifs antibiotic
portfolio and his considerable
experience in the paramedics pace prior
to join CTS dr. Couvillion earned his
PhD and molecular physiology and
biophysics at Vanderbilt University and
spent many years as a postdoctoral
fellow at the Harvard Medical School he
has dedicated much of his career using
envelop and finna be based methods and a
saint currently Covina is responsible
for coordinating CST antibody
reproducibility efforts working with
both internal and external scientists to
ensure the sea st meets or exceeds the
industry standards for an antibody
validation I'll now turn it over to the
doctor for his presentation hi everybody
and welcome to the webinar again my name
is Anthony khoobi on and what I'd like
to talk to you guys about today is how
to use antibodies and what CFCs take is
on antibody validation and
reproducibility and way I'd like to do
that its first talk a little bit about
CST about myself and why you should even
believe what I'm telling you today but
then go back a little bit and talk about
the reasons for why reproducibility is
an important topic what the causes are
who is responsible CST's role in
validation and reproducibility and then
discuss a little bit about what's being
done to address the problem not only
from CST's perspective but also from the
NIH and other players and at the end
we'll take some questions as we just
heard CST is a private global company it
was founded by a group of PhDs from mgh
in Harvard with the goal in mind of
generating reagents useful reagents that
researchers could use to enable
preclinical discovery CST is focused on
application driven antibody validation
we put a lot of effort into quality
control and our tech support internally
we've developed three generations of
rabbit monoclonal technologies and that
leads us to be able to generate
recombinant rabbit monoclonal antibodies
directly from polyclonal and that's our
latest technology as a matter of fact
ninety-four ninety-five percent of our
rabbit monoclonal antibodies are indeed
recombinant we do all of our
manufacturing in house that is a hundred
percent of the antibodies that we sell
are manufactured right here in Danvers
Massachusetts in an ISO 9001 certified
facility and we develop over ninety-five
percent of our products just briefly a
little bit about me just so you know
where I'm coming from in this area I've
been working in labs for a very very
long time first is a research associate
then as a graduate student in the
postdoctoral fellow like many of you I'm
sure half now the interesting thing
about this is that every time I've
worked in one of these fields I've been
in very antibody-dependent labs
everything from you know studying Syrian
treating kinase is at Harvard to G
proteins and GPCRs at Vanderbilt during
my graduate career and the thing that
always struck me in each of these
studies is I'm sure many of you are
familiar with is that oftentimes
antibodies are one of the limiting steps
in in your hypothesis-driven research
either there's issues with lack of
availability of a specific antibody the
specificity of the antibody that you buy
from a vendor or it's not clear exactly
if the antibody works for the
application you're interested in or you
know you transition from being a
graduate student to a postdoctoral
fellow and you change methodologies so
you're using techniques that you're no
longer familiar with in my case I went
from never doing flow cytometry to doing
almost exclusively flow cytometry and
there was a learning curve in there and
standing how to use antibodies that had
been used widely by others and that I
just couldn't get to work in my own
hands the bottom line was that you know
I spent two years of my life in graduate
school using an antibody from a company
that turned out to be nonspecific and
part of the fault was mine for not
taking the time upfront to validate the
antibody to make sure that it was
specific up front but often times as
many of you know when you're in a lab
and your your bosses asking you to churn
out data for a publication or whatnot
you trade off production / taking that
second step and wanting to make sure
that the reagent is correct and so part
of the reason that I came to CST and one
of the reasons that many folks are here
is because we've all had that experience
we've all been in a lab where we work
with an antibody that has turned out to
be incorrect and you end up wasting time
resource at your own sanity in order to
you know get your experiments to work so
in coming to CST like I said I've been
here for seven years much of that time
has been spent doing antibody
development and that's everything from
selecting the targets to assisting with
the design of the antigen to doing all
the validation work that goes into
producing a product that then as was
bought by our customers and so I'm
showing here just a few examples of the
antibodies that I developed I've
developed probably over a hundred
antibodies mostly in the map kinase
calcium signaling face but a few
outliers in there as well and in every
case I was didn't want a student or a
user of my products to have to go
through the issues that I went through
so everything that I did and everything
that we do here is CST is all about
ensuring that we make the highest
quality product possible we want people
to be able to use our antibodies right
out of the box as they would expect them
to work so
part of the problem with reproducibility
is the way that we choose antibodies and
the way that I see it is that there are
a few different options when you're
first looking for an antibody you can go
to the scientific literature and try to
see how an antibody was used and you and
I all know that there are two issues you
face right the first is that you find
the manuscript using google scholar or
pubmed and you locate the antibody the
experiment you want to use and the
authors don't actually cite it or my
favorite case of course is the one where
they they say oh it was used exactly it
was used in the previous paper you have
the previous paper down theta that
reference another paper and so on and so
forth and so one of the problems with
the scientific literature is that there
are no citations the methods are
incomplete or there's no details about
the antibody that we use the other place
you can go is to look at producers
websites and as many of you have
probably known producers either don't
offer the product or it's very difficult
to understand how they validated the
antibody companies can show data but
data showing staining in a Cell is not
validation that's just showing you that
the antibody detects something doesn't
tell you exactly what it is and some
companies do a better job than others of
showing that kind of validation data at
CST we hope that we're extremely
transparent we're not perfect but as we
go we do a do better and better job of
showing exactly the data exactly the
systems that were used to validate the
antibody and I'll discuss that in a long
more detail in the future one thing to
be cautious of and something that's kind
of popped up more and more lately are
the presence of resellers so if you
often go to bio compare or any other
antibody search engine a lot of times
the places that pop up our companies
that are just reselling other company's
products and they don't ever make it
clear unless the clone name is the same
that the product is exactly the same as
what the mother company is offering
so we've heard from many many different
customers that when they set out to do a
new product project if they want to
stain a new target by IHC for example
they'll go out and they'll buy five or
six different antibodies from five or
six different companies and they'll
they'll test them out the reality is
that depending on the target three or
four of those antibodies could be
exactly the same product formulated
slightly differently but basically
you're being resold the same product in
a rebranded way and so there's a lot of
lot of caution needs to be used when
purchasing antibodies from what I will
call a non producer or a reseller there
are also search engines and aggregators
that you can use to look up antibody
information antibody resource Google
antibodypedia for example and there are
a lot more and more of these that are
coming out and I think that these are
beginning to be a really useful resource
for people to find antibodies I 50
compare is probably one of the most used
but a lot of times what you have to
realize what these sites is that the
vendors are paying for placement of some
of these this information on their sites
and so the top results that turn up or
not always the best antibodies they're
just the first ones were listed a lot of
these sites do have reviews which I
think are helpful but you have to use
caution when doing that do the review
show data for example the other thing is
and we've seen this as well is that some
of these sites will often aggregate the
data from a bunch of different vendors
so that you can never quite tell which
data is associated with with janna body
and I think that that's confusing and
creates a problem you can also often
reach out to your colleagues and peers
and similar to reaching to digging into
the sign sort of literature the problem
that you have is that people may not
remember exactly which antibody they
used more importantly they not may not
remember which lot they used and there
are variations especially with
polyclonal antibodies from walked a lot
and so you have to be really careful
about so why is this important some of
you may be familiar with
the global biological Standards
Institute which is headed by Len
Friedman and dr. Friedman did a really
interesting study with a group of
acronis a few years back in which they
looked at scientific reproducibility in
the preclinical environment and made
some estimates both bottom-up and
top-down to try to understand how much
of academic research is not reproducible
and they found they estimated based on
the number of studies that over fifty
percent of all preclinical research is
not reproducible that amounts to of a
waste of 28 point two billion dollars in
NIH funding that's given to academic
researchers every year now that fifty
percent number may vary other studies
have shown it to be higher other studies
have shown it to be lower but in general
fifty percent is a pretty good estimate
of how irreproducible research is and
it's not clear how much of that is due
to antibodies but for the most part what
the what Len Freeman's group found was
that biological reagents and materials
were probably the largest fraction do of
waste and that is everything from
identification of the reagent incorrect
reagents bad reagents poorly validated
reagents reagents used in the in the
wrong system and they found that that
made up that bulk of the waste a bulk of
the cause for a reproducible research
they also found that investigators who
didn't set their studies up properly or
cherry-pick data or didn't do enough
biological replicates also contributed
pretty highly to that number so study
design and the data analysis and report
out were also a large chunk of that
review reproducible research and then
finally the use of protocols and that is
that protocols that are not completely
written or don't document everything or
are just in somebody's head were the
cause of the smallest cause but still a
significant cause of that lack of
reproduce
and so this is important because the
research that's done in the precooked
preclinical environment is what drives
the discoveries that go on in the
clinical environment and so if the
information is being developed in a
preclinical phase of a research project
is mistaken or incorrect or incomplete
then it means that we're slower getting
to it to cures were slowly slower
getting to discoveries or worse yet
we're actually making bad Diagnostics
bad therapeutics based on incorrect data
and there has been a history of this
happening so a couple of recent studies
again one from the gbesi and another one
from ammonia baker's group as nature did
a series of surveys and out of those
surveys of scientists research
scientists they found that there were a
number of causes general causes that
contributed to the reproducibility
within the lab and in order of employed
which of them in order importance here
so the survey results indicated that
incomplete reporting of data was the
number one and that means cherry-picking
information reagent variability and lack
of validation were number two and number
three and reagent variability is watch a
lot consistency resellers consistency
people using different versions of the
same thing or not knowing exactly what
they're using or not doing validation
and so that's that's a really big
problem if those two things are right up
there at the top experimental bias also
came up people you've not understanding
how to do enough biological replicates
doing experiments without statistical
basis or selectively reporting the
results made up a large chunk of the
issue as well but then again there was
it was an incorrect interpretation in
this conduct we're by far the smallest
factors in this so what it really came
to act comes down to at least for me and
and so signaling is that
we can break all of these down into
three basic categories and so the way we
feel and ended and a couple of recent
meetings would support this I'll talk
about those in a bit is that really all
of the issues come down to three
problems and adequate training and
support littered little or no region
identification for methods reporting and
poorly validated or misused antibodies
and at CST we call those the 3 m's of
reproducibility and I'm going to watch
her this very very quickly so we feel
that reproducibility comes down to three
things methods materials and mentoring
and i'll talk about mentoring first so
CST feels that one of the biggest
problems is that there's a lack of basic
training of flaccid lack of basic
knowledge of antibodies and we see this
with our own tech support which is that
we have users call in that are just
unfamiliar with how to use an antibody
and especially younger investigators
this was also reflected in the GPS I
look for aren't familiar with how to
validate an antibody or don't see the
need to validate an antibody and while
the vendor should do a lot of that work
for you the bottom line is that you
still need to validate the antibody in
your own system in your own hands to
make sure that it's going to work in
your specific system I'll talk more
about that a bit there seems to be a
broad misunderstanding that an antibody
that works by western blot doesn't
necessarily also work for IHC or another
application and if there's one message
you take home from this webinar today
it's that performance in one application
does not predict performance in another
and so whenever you take an antibody and
use it in a different application you
need to revalidate that antibody and
I'll talk about that in a lot more
detail a bit and again students and
scientists learning how to understand
and interpret their data set their data
set their experiments up correctly on
using the same methods over and over
again and understand the difference
between biological replicates and
technical replicates was cited in both
as being a problem finally we feel that
tech support is a component of mentoring
and that would you have an issue with
the company's reagent whether it be an
antibody or anything else you should be
able to call that company and get help
whether it be guidance a protocol
whatnot that companies should play a
role in that mentoring process methods
on the other hand fall mostly unto
making sure that they're clear and
detailed they're complete their
available traceable and that they can be
replicated repeated and this is really
important and I'll talk about this when
I talk about the role of journals
scientists and vendors in this space and
a fly finally the materials that you use
to do your experiments need to be highly
validated you need to use them properly
as I just alluded to that an antibody
performance in one experiment in one
application doesn't predict how it will
perform in another the materials need to
be easily identified they need to be
consistent and that could be lot to lock
consistency or that could be used to use
consistency and they need to be stable
and I'll talk about those concepts in a
second so who's responsible for each of
these areas and what I would argue is
that principal investigators and their
institutions should be responsible for
the mentoring and methods component of
the 3 m's and that is that principal
investigators and institutions should be
training their students in statistical
analysis in how to set up experiments in
the proper use of reagents and protocols
and they need to be able to document
those to show that they need to just
teach basic good laboratory practices
and keeping notebooks and things like
that and that if principal investigators
and institutions play a greater role in
here there would be less of a reproduce
ability issue we realize that this is
difficult for a lot of investigators do
their busy writing grants etc but still
we feel that this is an important
initiative and and I think that coming
into the few
there will be more and more effort by
institutions to help train special
younger scientists scientists or the
people using the reagents are
responsible for the materials and
methods you could also argue there are
somewhat responsible for mentoring those
underneath them but for this purpose i'm
going to make them / wamp predominantly
responsible for the materials and
methods so the materials and methods
means that you should again identify the
materials that you're using clearly
document the protocols that you're using
and make sure that other people can
replicate the experiments that you're
doing I think that that's very important
and the scientists are a little bit more
careful with how they use reagents and
how they document how they use reagents
some of this reproducibility situation
will be mitigated we also think that
journals are complicit in ensuring that
materials and methods are clearly
documented and clearly identified in
their journals as I alluded to early on
the top there are all sorts of times of
when you go to a journal they're clearly
lots of western blots in the article
they're clearly lots of western blots in
the article sorry I think we've gone why
there are clearly lots of western blots
in the article and the be the sorry
forgive me there lots of western blots
in the article but nowhere are their
citations indicated for the antibody and
so it's important that the journals
established rules and guidelines to show
what you need to do to indicate properly
cite and properly reference antibody
music at CST we feel that CSP itself and
vendors are responsible for all three of
the MS and that is that we need to make
sure that we carefully document our
methods we need to make sure that we
clearly identify and make are the
materials the antibodies that we're
providing you extremely consistent and
that we're providing you textable tech
support so that we're mentoring and
assisting with the experiment
and how do we do that so at CST we use
application driven antibody development
which means that all of the protocols
that that we show on our website have
been optimized for that application for
that antibody when we make those
protocols those detailed protocols
clearly available on our website in an
app specific manner so that if you go to
our website and you're using a specific
product you can find out more
information and we have significant data
to show that even changing the percent
of formaldehyde in the fixation
conditions of an IHC or if' experiment
can have disastrous effects on the
outcome of the experiment so we put a
lot of effort into validating the
products as we go and hope that our
users can benefit from that by following
those same protocols we realized that's
not always the case but that's where
tech support comes in because oftentimes
we've tested our antibodies under other
conditions as well it can help provide
some insight as to the effect of say
using milk or BSA to block during the
primary or block or use 4%
paraformaldehyde versus three percent
during the fixation step when we provide
our technical support we should be
helping you understand wine antibody
didn't work if it didn't work or how to
improve your results and sometimes
that's as simple as providing a separate
protocol but other times that involves a
lengthy troubleshooting process we also
have a application experts so that in
other words the people when you call our
tech support line you're not directed to
somebody who then routes your call
you're actually directed to the people
who validated the antibody by that
application so if you have an IHC
question you talked to the IHC team if
you have analyzed a question you talked
to the Eliza we also offer a number of
tutorials and application guides that
should help with commonly asked
questions we offer on-site training for
some of our more difficult applications
such as our proteomics work and we
collaborate widely with investigators
not only investigators developing new
methods but investigators who are trying
to use our antibody for a method that
that we haven't validated the product
and we do this as a way of ensuring that
our antibodies are handled and used in a
way that's consistent with our own
practices so that when other customers
want to use the antibody and that method
they can they can benefit from previous
customers work the material that CST
makes are tested for specificity
sensitivity reactivity consistency
stability and manufacturing as I meant
to mention earlier we manufacture a
hundred percent of our antibodies in
house which means that everything that
goes out the door has been tested by one
of our production teams and I'll walk
through that process in a minute the
stability issue is a big one I think
most people aren't aware of is that
rabbit monoclonal antibodies especially
recombinant rabbit monoclonal antibodies
are pretty stable however before we send
anything out the door we store it at 37
degrees for one week to make sure that
it performs as well before and app and
after it went into those conditions and
so many of our products are shipped
according to their civility and that's
clearly indicated on the day issue from
a consistency perspective we test every
lot of a new product in every up in
every approved application before the
new robot is released and we make sure
that they hope the new lot looks just
the same as the old lot when we release
those products and I'll show you an
example of that in a bit but first I
want to walk you through a little bit of
what how we show data and all the
processes we go through to validate
antibodies in the hopes that you can
start using some of these in your own
lab to make decisions on purchasing
antibodies have been also save yourself
time and effort when you're using an
antibody and in the system this is a
typical data sheet the same informations
available on our web page but on this
data sheet we show information about the
approved applications and the tested
species that the antibody has been used
in and when we say approved application
that means that here are the
applications that we've tested this
antibody an and the antibody has passed
we don't indicate any applications that
have failed or were not tested if you
need that information you can't all are
all our tech support
line and in the future we will make that
information available to users we also
indicate the species that the antibody
works against some antibodies were able
to test a large number of species others
were only able to test a few but by
default we always test in human mouse
and rat and make that information
available where possible if we list a
species in parentheses it means that the
antigen is a hundred percent identical
over that antigenic range and we only
list those species that are a hundred
percent achill we don't make any
assumptions we also list the storage
conditions we list the applications
additional information about the
applications the dilution that the
antibody was used and the buffers now
one shortcoming that we realize is that
many customers like to see the
concentration of the antibody we don't
actually list that on our data sheets we
are going to start putting that on what
we call our certificate of analysis
which is a lot specific piece of
information that will be attached to
each product on the webpage but in the
meantime if you need that information
you can always call our tech support
line and they will gladly give you the
information we also indicate the
specificity of the antibody and this is
especially relevant if there are family
members that against the against the
target and so we will clearly state as
best of our knowledge that whether an
antibody cross reacts with an isoform we
also talked about the sensitivity and
give you the antigen information finally
by default on all of our data sheets
where an antibody is a proof of Western
blot we will give a very quick piece of
detail about the Western blotting
conditions and that includes the
dilution the blocking and the primary
conditions and the reason for this is
that some of our antibodies work really
really well in milk and really really
poorly in BSA and vice versa and so by
default we test all of our antibodies by
western blot using both milk and BSA as
the primary element and when we do that
we get really divergent results now
sometimes it doesn't make any difference
but many times it makes a significant
difference especially for
phospho specific antibodies and so we
attempt to make that front and center a
piece of detail that you can easily
refer to to understand how to optimize
your Western blot conditions and so when
using an antibody from any company I
encourage you to use a variety of
different buffer conditions in order to
optimize performance the analog so why
do we go through all of this effort to
make the antibodies that we do and part
of the reason is that we've listened to
our customers we are teams traveled
widely we have over 250 active sign
scientific collaborations as of today
and we have we host scientists all the
time at our facility to come give talks
so we spend a lot of time talking to
scientists to understand what it is they
need what it is they want and how we can
make their antibody use more seamless
and we spend a lot of our money
reinvesting back in our antibody
development pipeline and I think that
CST is unique in the fact that because
we're privately-owned we can do that and
so it's really great to be in an
environment where we're developing new
technologies we are investing heavily in
new platforms for antibody validation
and we are investing in the people that
validate those antibodies we take a
premarket post market approach to
antibody selling and that is that we
engage scientists up front to understand
what products we need to develop but
then in the end we also need to continue
to support those products by engaging
customers to understand is something not
working right what new applications that
we need to try this test this antibody
for how can we make this product better
and meet new needs our antibody
development process looks a lot like
this and I'm not going to go through
this and a whole lot of detail but this
is how we make a typical rabbit
monoclonal antibody it starts with
target selection we then design the
project based on the application
requirements species requirements etc we
then immunize and bleed the animals we
through a round of application testing
and again the applications chosen at
this point are dictated by the target of
the antibody for example if we made a
PDL one antibody for Western blot only
it probably wouldn't be that useful to
investigators so we make units to
chemistry the primary driver for that
reagent and then we test that antibody
by IHC up front we then go through a
series of molecular cloning steps to
ensure that we're capturing the antibody
that goes through another round of
application testings to make sure that
the clone that we selected early on
again as the clone after were common and
cloning there's a set of final clone
selections yet another round of
application testing and then that's when
the product is developed and provided
over to production to be made as a
larger lot that lot has been made and
then tested by an independent group so
our production group and our development
groups are independent so the teams that
are doing the law testing are different
from those that are doing all the
development testing so every product is
being tested by at least two different
teams before it goes out the door and
those teams have to agree on the quality
of the product before we release it I'd
like to say that everything that we take
on becomes a product but that's not the
case so most of our are well almost half
of our antibody projects end up failing
at some point during the process so we
actually throw away just as many
projects as we end up making in the
products which i think is a huge
attrition rate but it also goes to show
how important our antibody principles
and our validation steps are out of
interest in time I'm going to go through
this very quickly but in general these
are our antibody principles validation
principles we determine specificity
sensitivity consistency who optimize the
methods and we provide high quality tech
support and what I'd like to do is drill
down a little bit more detail about a
couple of these the first being
sensitivity the other being consistency
and so I want to show you some examples
now of how we use specificity to
validate antibodies this table is
designed to be an incomplete example of
how we
of the methods that we use to determine
specificity I want to call to your
attention specifically the use of
positive or negative tissues or use of
knockouts to make sure that the antibody
is specific and by way of example we're
using immunofluorescence to look in
positive and negative cell lines to make
sure is the antibody specific now again
this particular experiment just shows
the antibody a specific by mean
fluorescence doesn't say anything about
how it performs by western blot so you
have to do the same specificity analysis
that you would do by western blot that
you do in this example and we never best
just do one method we often use multiple
methods to confirm specificity for
immunofluorescence in particular and
then sometimes for western blotting will
use subcellular localization is an
indicator of specificity if you have a
cytoplasmic protein and it stains the
nucleus then you probably don't have a
specific antibody we will also use cell
fractionation to test antibodies by
western blot but for the most part
anything that is not specific in
localizations in one application with
that cousin is in question results about
the other applications unless we can
provide it was using agonists or
inhibitors or growth conditions to shift
the protein around is also critically
important to validating an antibody CST
offers a wide array of fausto and
modification specific antibodies and in
these cases we often very often use
treatments to in order to ensure to
convince ourselves that the antibody is
correct again we will also use positive
and negative cell lines but the
treatment condition really gives us the
right information that we're looking for
we often compare our products against
those from other companies this was
actually a product that I made the top
image prosthetic acid phosphatase was
tested both by western blot and by
administer emmis tree against the top
competitor and the 4lj clone which is
sold by or used in it as a clinical
diagnostic marker and so we will often
screen are antibodies against these
competitor to see where do we stand is
ours better worse or
same as competitor antibody and
oftentimes we will only sell it if it's
if it's an improvement on the market
finally we'll use other techniques such
as this case is using cell pellets to
pre-screen for immunohistochemistry and
so what you're looking at here is the
CST antibody highlighted in blue or a
non CST antibody which is on the right
hand side in net positive cells in the
top two boxes or mint- cells in the
bottom three boxes using CST's new anti
net antibody and you can see that in our
hands what we're saying is nice specific
staining in the net positive cells no
staining in the net negative cells
whereas a competitor antibody stains
equivalently if not more so in the
negative cells in terms of consistency
we take great we go to great lengths to
ensure that every lot of our product is
exactly the same as the previous lot so
that if you're switching loss you're not
suddenly going to start getting new
results and this is just one of many
examples that I have this is a rabbit
polyclonal antibody it's one of our best
selling products number 9101 it against
phospho work and what you can see in
this image is that one of the very early
o'clocks that we made this cone night
wat 10 rabbit polyclonal was released in
1999 and i'm showing you examples of
additional lots that were sold after
that because it's since been retired so
lot made in 2000 2002 etc you can see
that at least by western blot every
single lot it looks exactly the same as
all the other wats we go through great
lengths to make sure that our
formulations are correct and we would
follow up by also testing all of these
Lots by AF and by the other approved
applications to make sure that the
product performs equivalently exactly
the same dilution in every single
application for which the product is
approved from a tech support question as
I've said many times it's very important
to go through
if you're having an issue with one of
our products please call and somebody
will help you can also email or go to
our website to submit a form I want to
spend a couple seconds talking about
what others are doing to address
reproducibility and so there have been a
really great number of initiatives that
have been proposed for example there are
now some region ID repositories such as
the RR ID system that's been proposed
and being used by some journals and
they're also protocol sites I'm just
citing an example of protocols i/o which
is being used to track reagents not only
in labs but in publications and track
the use of protocols I encourage you to
check both of those out as a way of
citing and reviewing protocols and
reagents in the literature and in your
own work a number of really good
antibody search engines have become
available and again ones that link to
the vendor are probably the best the
ones that are that offer to sell you a
product or probably just resellers but a
lot of these engines do a really nice
job of tying a product to a number of
citations or end user data and I find
that to be really useful in terms of
finding out which antibodies are most
widely used most highly published or
highly rate highly recommended by others
journals had started to make a slow
change in terms of encouraging better
citations and better user behavior by
implementing checklists making sure that
authors are actually listing the
antibodies correctly in current use of
proper methods I know cell presses
launch star I as I mentioned above some
journals are working with our ID group
to ensure that our ideas are used to
cite antibodies and there are a number
of individual journals in which the
editors have come out to say you need to
be more careful about how you list
inside your antibodies the NIH has
started a program of rigor attribute
civilian research and they've launched
some efforts into finding ways to ensure
greater reproducibility and greater
accountability and research side AB a
group out of the UK launched a meeting
in earlier in 2016 to bring together
scientists and other vendors and
journals to talk about antibody
validation but most importantly the
gbesi which is again the global
biological standards Institute recently
held an antibody validation workshop as
part of their reproducibility initiative
and they invited vendors research
scientists journal editors funding
agencies and antibody database experts
and searched repository leaders to come
together to discuss what's wrong with
antibody validation and what needs to be
done to fix it out of that meeting came
a number of initiatives and one that I'd
like to highlight again as I've
mentioned is the need for greater region
or resource identify identification in
the literature etc and so this is where
I think our IDs makes a huge impact on
tracking not only the reagents that are
used in papers but eventually other
information such as the wat the dilution
things like that the vendors are
beginning to work with the gbesi to
adopt a set of validation standards and
those are being worked on now and so
you'll have to stay tuned for those but
basically the standards that they're
coming up with if you're familiar with
the five pillars workflow that was
published earlier and this year in
nature methods or things that that to be
honest CST is already doing we still
have some work to do but for the most
part we feel that we're already hearing
to those validation standards we also
make sure that we use detailed protocols
that was another topic of discussion of
the GBS I meeting and so we like to
think that we're ahead of the curve on
that but again can do a better job we
also another tough piece of topic that
came out of the gbesi meeting was the
need for vendors to show to have
increased transparency to show more data
to talk about where the day the antibody
is derived from so to make resellers
more accountable for what their
reselling and to show
more application application specific
validation data researchers as I
mentioned earlier were tasked with
finding ways to better train or better
mentor especially the younger students
in their lab and to increase the use of
the reagent identification resources
that i mentioned earlier so until the
working group comes up with guidelines
validation guidelines I just want to
close by offering a few my own advice
based on experience in my work here on
how to find a good antibody and it
starts with looking at the data
reviewing the data both for that
provided by the vendor any data any
publications where the antibody is used
I'll be at that that's difficult to find
but the search tools now are becoming
better at doing that and looking for how
the antibody is about it does the vendor
show testing data or validation data and
that's what is really critical and you
need to look at the applications that
you're using because again like I said
if there's one thing that you need to
take away from this is that an aunt that
an antibody works if an antibody works
in one application it doesn't guarantee
performance in another and so you need
to look if you want to use an antibody
for chip was the antibody validated for
chip is the data look like it's quality
data did the vendor or the person who
developed the antibody use the correct
gene targets to validate their chip you
need to look at and review the data very
very clearly and if the vendor doesn't
show it you should call them and ask
them you also want to check to make sure
that the species reactivity is correct
for the model that you're using if a
vendor sells an antibody and it was
raised against human protein there's no
guarantee it will work for Mouse so you
need to make sure that that the vendor
actually tested for mouse and you can
either look on their website CST makes
this clearly available or you should be
able to call and find out the vendor
should provide protocols especially
application specific protocols for how
to use the antibody preferably the
dilution or a very tight dilution ring
not kills me when people say to
determine by end user because that
doesn't make any sense you're having to
redo a bunch of validation data for the
vendor and so I would suggest looking
for vendors and not only offer specific
protocols but give you narrow ranges on
how to use the antibody now you're going
to have to do some titration on your own
in especially for some applications but
for the most part at least they can give
you some guidance as to where to start
and we're bad if it's important to you
you might want to look at the type of
antibody where common in antibodies tend
to be at least rabbit and mouse for
common antibodies tend to be much more
reproducible and polyclonal antibodies
but if polyclonal is the only thing
that's available you want to see about
the lot to lot consistency is this
something that you're going to make a
big discovery on one day and find out
that you can't reproduce it six months
from now because the vendor is going to
switch to a new law you may also want to
review peer-reviewed citations find out
where the antibody was used how it was
used if the vendor didn't approve the
application you're looking for it's
somebody else use it that way can you
find out any more information does the
vendor offer technical support to be
able to help you if you have a problem
and all companies should direct you
right to a somebody who can give you
true technical support not just send you
a free tube of antibody I would also
like to say that some reviews are
helpful but I would use these with
caution because not all reviews product
reviews on websites are accurate I
prefer to use the ones in which somebody
has actually supplied the data to go
along with it and so I would use those
with a grain of salt and with that I
will close and say that if anybody has
any questions i encourage you to either
go ahead and email me directly my email
address is up on the screen or if you go
to ww cell signal calm and browse the
about Us section of our of our top
navigation we have a page dedicated to
our antibody validation principles and
now in the future there will be a lot
more detail about our validation
processes the transparency that we are
going to implement and some of the
changes that we're going to make
way that we do or antibody validation
because like I said we're not perfect
but we are we think right where we need
to be in terms of high-quality product
development and distribution so with
that I will close and say thank you to
everyone well thank you so very much for
that informative presentation now before
we get started on the question answer
session I would like to remind our
audience Henderson questioned you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green two and a button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and we'll try to answer as many
questions as it can our first question
sir monocles do provide the epitope
sequence information you provide
information about cross relativity of
epitopes overlap example a bee that
binds to a protein epitome versus
another that binds to the same region
when phosphorylated yes so we started
doing a lot more of that now i think as
it's become clear that post
translational modifications that occur
very very closely to each other can
affect antibody binding if you're trying
to detect one post translational
modification and and there's another
nearby post translational modification
it might change we do foremost for our
antibodies that are raised against
peptides if you we are going to make
those peptide sequences available on our
website currently they are not we give
you the information about the region
around which the antibody was designed
but if you call our tech support line
they will give you that infant they will
provide that that information to our
academic customers the reason we don't
is because there's proprietary issues
around the antigen design and things
like that but for the most part to our
academic researchers is not a problem
the the answer the question is that we
use a number of techniques to determine
the specificity of the antibodies that
are near multiple PT ms the first is
that we've been using for a while now
antibody arrays in which we spot a
peptide arrays in which we spot a number
of different
peptides each containing a different
iteration of the post-translational
modifications in that region we sponsor
peptides at varying concentrations and
then use the antibody to determine its
specificity the other way we do this is
to make either knockouts so we've done
this for a number of project what will
make serine to alanine mutations or you
know other mutations to try to see if
the antibody still reacts with the
protein when we mutated or otherwise
modify the site and so I hope that our
are antibodies we try to make a specific
as possible using as many methods as we
possibly can in some cases it's very
difficult but we do we do our best and
we will provide this information if it's
needed thank you what are some
differences that you've experienced
which we come to antibodies a monoclonal
antibodies I'm sorry can you repeat the
question oh yes I told you what are some
of the differences youth experience with
recombinant antibodies and monoclonal
antibodies oh yes good question thank
you so recombinant again is all that
we've done is taken the antibody and
expressed it in a heterologous system
and what we find with antibodies derived
from hybridomas whether it's a mouse or
rabbit is that there's some locked a lot
variability mouse monoclonal in
hybridoma are relatively stable but
rabbit monoclonal czar are much less so
and so what we find when we develop the
recombinant clone is that we get much
greater consistency lots of lot
performance goes goes way up and we
don't risk actually losing the antibody
due to the crash of the of the hybridoma
so we're going in that direction because
it makes our reagents a lot more
consistent
but in terms of performance by
application we found that there is no
recombinant antibodies let me put it
this way there's no evidence to suggest
that recombinant antibody performs any
better than a traditional monoclonal
antibody in any application we still
have to validate a recombinant antibody
you have to test every lot because there
can be depending on how you culture
yourself differences from lots a lot
which is why we make all of our common
antibodies under very carefully
controlled circumstances but for the
most part when you hear people say that
recombinant antibodies are better I'm
not sure that there's evidence to
support that production and manufacture
is easier but they're not necessarily
any better than their counterparts and
some people actually argue that
polyclonal is because they recognize
multiple motifs actually give you
greater performance in some applications
and and and I would buy that argument
thank you I use anti ments antibodies to
city antigen and lizard king is this a
reasonable valid or no I'm sorry can you
repeat the question yes I use anti-mouse
antibodies to study antigen and wizard
kidney is the result valid or no I don't
have enough experience to be able to
answer that question sorry thank you for
antibodies that are not available to CST
welcome suggestions for mental body
targets to be designed absolutely so we
I can't bring up the website right now
but we do have a place on our website
where you can suggest a new target or if
you can contact your sales
representative the way that it works is
that our sales representatives will take
those suggestions and bring them to our
development scientists who will it will
then consider them
my question is related to the spec shin
and reagent use for validation and most
of the CST Roman to belgian file i
apologize the question is how can we
address a youth the cft antibody in ours
or one application as a part of the
scientific rigor yes so it is my
understanding that's a good question but
it's my understanding that the NIH
office of rigor and reproducibility is
engaging a new system and grants in
which they're more highly vetted and so
my guess is that in the very new future
grants are going to have to include some
sort of validation data for some of the
materials being used I don't know I
don't remember there was a conversation
around this very issue but I honestly
don't remember what the outcome of that
discussion was whether or not the vendor
data would be sufficient I think the
reason it wouldn't be is that if the
vendor hasn't tested the antibody in the
application and the cell line or tissue
that you plan on using that the vendor
data would not be sufficient so for
example if if we show or the vendor
shows reactivity in hela cells and
you're using mouse brain samples you may
actually have to show that the antibody
it validates in mouse brain instead of
providing the vendor data unless the
vendor data has done that experiment for
you can you also write the IHC antibody
or test on automated system and maybe
share the protocol as well that's
another terrific question we
historically have not used auto
standards only because we don't have
access to one we are in the next few
weeks about to bring in an auto stainer
to CST
and we'll start to validate some of our
IHC antibodies for use in an auto
scanner and we'll make that that
application and protocols available to
on the website and upon request if
anybody needs it are there any instances
where the choice of the secondary has
consequences on the quality of the
result and do you always use the same
one and do you do any testing with
multiple antibodies that's another good
question so at CST as we're doing the
testing process we use our own secondary
antibodies so that we don't have to buy
them from anybody does the secondary
antibody make a difference absolutely
the dilution that you use a secondary
antibody in especially for western
blotting that the dilution makes a huge
impact on the signals noise ratio on how
dirty that the background is and we do
occasionally will test our competitors
secondary antibodies we typically don't
make that information available we do it
for our own purposes but in general yes
the choice of the secondary antibody and
how you use it makes a huge difference
and I would recommend that the first
time you use a new antibody you should
also do a titration with your secondary
to make sure that you're using that
enough an optimal concentration as well
okay talk briefly about the role of
buffers and it's important when IHC and
link it with the retrieval solutions
please absolutely so it we find very
often that we can the difference between
an antibody working or not with them is
entirely due to a number of factors the
fixation conditions the age of the
fixative so how fresh your buffers are
the antigen retrieval methods and the
conditions under which you do antigen
retrieval all of these have a huge
impact we've worked with a number of
large clinical labs that when they're
doing clinical trials often see wide
variability and the antibody staining
pattern because there's no consistency
over how the antibody or how the
material was fixed the age how long its
atmos it is we find these to be really
really critical components in how an
antibody performs in an IHD assay IHC
and validation by IHC is almost kind of
its own universe people that do a lot of
IHC will tell you that you really need
to validate an IHC antibody from scratch
in your system we do as much as we
possibly can to facilitate that and so
one thing that we do do if you're doing
IHC is that we do make available control
slides that will allow you to that we
have tested internally with our own
antibody so that you can take those
control slides and run them through your
own protocol with our antibody to make
sure that our antibody is still working
so I encourage you to use vendors that
do that kind of thing we also provide
lysate controls for western blots and
things like that as a way of controlling
for sample preparation variability that
occurs nice question now is you related
to the spreadsheet and the agents used
for validation and most of the CST
expect she'd only see a few agents
mentioned such as diluting and detection
reagents do you use most commonly used
free agents such as Madame PBS and
diluting or different secondary reagents
we use pretty common buffers a few of
our antibodies work in and buffers that
are specific for them and we typically
call them out on our website under that
there's a each product page there's an
accordion that talks about that you can
open the talks about the protocols and
in that within that area you can
actually find out more details about the
buffer
opposition's that are used for some of
our reagents where that's not indicated
i would call our tech support line and
they can give you that information we
don't we don't make none of that the
buffers are a trade secret situation so
we're pretty open with that thinking an
old type of malaya new blinds are
recommended for validating antibodies
specific using a crisper oh yeah so
that's a good question we like we
typically like to use a cell line we use
many of the known genomic proteomic
databases to find cells that are
predicted to express high levels of our
protein of interest ideally we like to
use those cell lines to knock down using
crisper and the reason for that is that
some of the model systems that are
available out there such as the crisper
line from a plugin those cell lines
which we've used in house don't up
express all proteins and so you're going
to get a negative signal in should get a
negative signal in both the wild-type
and the knockdown cells so we prefer to
use the human cell lines that are
predicted to express decent levels of
the protein maybe not super high because
then it makes the crisper harder but
that we can confirm by western blot
Express a good amount of the protein of
interest and that then we can use
crisper to knock that down down or out
completely and dr. do you have any final
comments for today I don't I would just
say that if there are any questions I'm
more than happy to answer them my new
job here at CSP is to keep tabs on the
reproducibility initiative and to make
sure that we're supporting our customers
in any way possible to make sure that
their work is reproducible so if anybody
has any questions feel free to email me
if there are questions after the webinar
I would encourage the same
if you I'd also like to thank our
sponsor cell signaling technology for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
April 2017 you'll receive an email from
lathers alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay will invite
you to for that announcement to your
colleagues who have made miss today's
live event until next time goodbye